more states consider lockdowns to save
lives many businesses are bracing now
for new setbacks
that's according to yelp nearly 100 000
businesses permanently closed
because of the pandemic and that's just
through august the unemployment rate is
down since the spring but it's still at
6.7
nationwide our lead national
correspondent david bagno is in las
vegas david good morning to you we know
how much that city relies on tourism so
this pandemic has got to be having a
huge impact there it is but let me tell
you again when we arrived yesterday we
were all a little surprised as to how
busy the strip was now having said that
nevada has the second highest
unemployment rate in the country las
vegas is a big driver for that
but here in las vegas they are affected
by the governor's occupancy limit so the
nevada governor limited casinos bars
restaurants to about 25
occupancy but that is not keeping people
away in droves like you might expect
the famous las vegas strip is a little
less crowded in the age of coronavirus
but those we spoke to who are still
coming here say they feel safe
gambling their luck in sin city i've
seen people wiping down
you know games and stuff it's very quiet
and
i'm sure it's difficult for people here
to make a living
how hard hit has vegas been by coving
we got hit hard by the pandemic there's
no other way to look at it
that is jonas peterson he is ceo of the
las vegas global economic alliance
he says the city's unemployment numbers
hit great recession levels
but he says the hospitality industry is
primed for
a major comeback in 2021. the big key to
success is
that the vaccine so once that hits and
now has a program delivery schedule
i think you see a confidence return
but the vaccine is still months away for
most americans
and right now businesses across the
country are facing down
new restrictions in new york state
governor andrew cuomo warned that indoor
dining
could again stop in new york city that's
if the rate of covet hospitalizations
does not stabilize
soon if you overwhelm the hospital
capacity you will have to go back to
shut down there are no options
and in california some small business
owners are pleading with governor gavin
newsom
to reopen outdoor dining and salon
services
let us prove to you that we can do this
that we are being safe
and then there are the workers who say
they are close to losing everything
people like jeffrey gove gov was laid
off from his i-team management job at a
vegas casino back in may
and with a few casinos hiring there has
been
no income for himself and his wife who
uses a wheelchair
i'm 56 and i'm tapping my retirement
to survive now i have to hope for the
best but prepare for the worst
so for people like mr cove what's in
this proposed stimulus bill that the
congress is still debating we asked our
chief congressional correspondent nancy
cordes
and here's what she said there is
extended 300 a week federal unemployment
insurance
there's more money for loans for small
businesses there's also money for
cash-strapped cities
and states and local governments that
could help retain public employees
and gail there's also a good chance that
the bill is going to include according
to nancy
some rental assistance money that will
extend the eviction moratorium
and enable people who've fallen behind
on their rent to stay in their homes
all very encouraging to hear david but
let's just get it to the people that's
what we need at this point thank you
very much
thanks